what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just got episode four of Marvel's
secret Invasion and it threw us some
twists some that we definitely knew were
going to happen and some that we really
weren't expecting and if you are trying
to avoid any and all spoilers for secret
Invasion Episode 4. this is your
official spoiler warning we are going to
be breaking down everything that
happened in episode 4 so you have been
warned and with that being said we can
finally say Roadie is a scroll we all
predicted this we all kind of felt like
he was a scope and we were right but now
the question is how long exactly has
Rodi been a scroll and of course the
bigger question for this particular
episode is is Talos really dead Amelia
Clarke's Gaia was not dead but she was a
super scroll she went through the
experimentation that we found out in the
beginning of the episode and based off
of what we know Talos has never been
anywhere near that facility anywhere
near that machine so we could probably
say with confidence he is not a super
scroll so is he actually dead let us
know your thoughts right now in the
comments yes he's dead or no he's not
dead and he will be coming back we have
a lot to break down in this episode
including a very important scene one you
might not realize how important this
actually is for the future of the scroll
and the Human Alliance we'll break it
all down in this video and if you're new
be sure to subscribe to the channel to
stay up to date on the MCU and if you
both subscribe and comment your
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items a winner gets to pick one item and
we pick a winner at the end of each
month so this episode starts off with
Gaia the end of last episode she was
shot by graphic and we believed her to
be dead well some of us did some of us
knew that Gaia was actually a super
scroll and it showed us this of course
Gaia never truly trusted graphic
especially after she met with her dad
and learned that her mother had died so
due to her spine she realized that
graphic was making a machine to make
scroll stronger and we saw that she
seized her opportunity to jump in the
machine herself and become a superstar
and graphic as we saw in this episode
and as we knew from before is also a
super scroll now as well now in the
comics there was one super scroll he was
a specific character and he was created
as a Fantastic Four villain he was
literally created in the comic Universe
to take on the Fantastic Four and he was
given the powers of each of the members
of the Fantastic Four only stronger he
could stretch further than Mr Fantastic
he could turn invisible and create
stronger force fields than the invisible
woman he could burn hotter than the
Human Torch and he was stronger than the
thing now obviously this is not the case
in the MCU as we have seen that they
have taken samples from DNA of creatures
that we have seen in the MCU before to
make a super scroll the specimens that
we know about so far are Groot the
extremists obsidian coal and a frost
Beast now when Gaia is turning into a
super scroll it shows us the screen of
the supposed powers that she is going to
get however we are not actually sure if
she has all of the powers the extremist
is the one that is highlighted we can
see it on the left and we can see the
name extremis on the right side as well
and below that we can see that it says
healing abilities 100 heat strength one
hundred percent so they made it very
clear that the extremist is how they can
heal and this is also kind of a play off
of the Human Torch instead of the super
scroll getting the powers of the Human
Torch they get the powers of the
extremists they get the Heat and they
can also heal from this now we can see
on the left side of the screen behind
the sample that is ready it says Frost
beast and coal obsidian notice we don't
see Groot here of course it is possible
that she got all of these but perhaps
some are missing perhaps Groot is
missing for Gaia we do know however that
gravic has the abilities of group
because we see that at the end of this
episode and that's kind of a play on Mr
Fantastic's ability to stretch they
simply used Groot and his ability to
extend his limbs or branches so Gaia
survives and it makes us wonder what
exactly does it take to kill a super
scroll she was shot right in the chest
right where her heart is there was a big
hole there but she healed so she got
shot in the heart and was able to heal
graphic also gets shot in the face a
huge chunk of his face gets taken off
and it stuns Nick Fury to see so it does
make you wonder what exactly does it
take to kill a super scroll I'm sure
we're gonna find out at the end now of
course one of the biggest things about
this show is that it is about Nick Fury
and yes of course it's also about Gaia
and Talos and gravic but at its core
this is a Nick Fury story a story of him
and his history and current position
with the scroll so the scenes that we
get with his wife who is a scroll are
quite intense we start off with a
flashback to 2012 in Paris and this is
right after the events of the first
Avengers film in which of course Nick
Fury brought the Avengers team together
and there's something very interesting
in what Priscilla says here she
suspected that Nick Fury was the one
that brought them together of course she
is right and he pretty much tells her
that but when he asks why she isn't
surprised that he is the one that
brought them together she goes on about
how he has a good sense of right and how
he protects the weak and of course as
she's telling us this it tells us a lot
about Nick Fury's character of course
but also she is speaking of her people
the scroll how he basically was helping
them when they were weak but the
interesting part is is we think back to
the events of the first Avengers film
now that we know that Nick Fury has
known about the scroll for a very long
time at that point it gives us a little
bit more knowledge about a very
particular scene in the first Avengers
film where Captain America Bruce Banner
and Iron Man are kind of snooping around
the ship that they're on and basically
find out that Shield is making extremely
powerful weapons and Nick Fury says it's
because of him and he points to Thor and
Thor says my people mean you no harm but
Nick Fury says but your people aren't
the only people out there now obviously
now we know that Nick Fury knows about
the scroll and he also knows about the
cree so this gives us a little bit more
context he wasn't exactly making these
weapons to defend against Asgardian
specifically but actually to defend
against evil skrull or to defend against
the cree which he already knew about but
obviously at that time nobody knew about
the scroll so he couldn't exactly
mention them now Priscilla reads a poem
to Nick Fury called late fragment
actually she reads part of it while Fury
reads the other part and this is pretty
much a big setup for the scene that
takes place at their dinner table we
learned that Priscilla or the scroll
Bara has been working for grabik and the
scroll Rebels and she of course has
known that Roadie was indeed a scroll
the entire time in fact she has been
reporting to him so much that if he
calls her she goes to him but she is
still kept a little bit in the dark
because when she goes to tell Rody or
the scroll rava who was disguised as him
whose name is listed in the credits that
Fury was fired she didn't know that
Roadie was actually the person or rabba
was actually the person that fired him
now the scroll didn't exactly plan on
Fury being on Earth so Roadie or rava
tells Vara that she either has to kill
him or he's gonna kill her this is what
he meant when he said one of the two
occupants of that lovely country manner
of yours is catching a bullet today you
can flip a coin for all I care showing
how ruthless this scroll actually is now
of course Nick Fury being the Ultimate
Spy that he is is listening in on this
whole entire conversation so is waiting
for Vara when she comes home now he did
not put his wedding ring back on and she
notices this and of course he plays koi
but the real reason he doesn't put it on
is because his wife is planning on
killing him but before Vara and rava
depart Vara does try to get Nick Fury's
life to be spared she says that this is
not the old Nick Fury that we know this
is a new Nick Fury and he's not even
close to the same man that the old Nick
Fury was he is much less and of course
Fury is listening and you can tell that
he takes this rather personally a lot of
people have been saying this and he
knows it himself he is not the same old
Nick Fury he's not on top of his game
but it does show us that Vara really
does actually care for fury because
she's trying to get his life spared and
fury actually really cares for her as
well their marriage was real and he even
says by far you are the worst steak that
I have ever made but now that I know
everything I don't think I would go back
and do anything different he would do
the same thing again because he was in
love with her and apparently they had a
pretty good marriage which seems pretty
apparent since they both clearly love
each other because when faced with the
decision to kill the other person both
of them chose to not they both would end
up missing on purpose but Vara tells us
the story of how she got the identity of
the human form that she takes she took
the identity and actual life of a Dr
Priscilla Davis who was dying and this
part is pretty ambiguous it's hard to
tell if Nick Fury actually knew Dr
Priscilla Davis we did hear a rumor
about Vara slash prizilla not too long
ago that stated that Nick theory was in
love with somebody before she died and
then Vara took the place of her to fill
a void for Fury however that doesn't
seemingly line up too much perhaps that
was just a guess because the way this
conversation goes down it does doesn't
really seem like Nick Fury knew
Priscilla before although it is
certainly possible however since Nick
Fury is asking about the story of how
she chose the form that she is in it
makes us believe that he didn't actually
know the former Priscilla he had simply
never asked her the story of why she
chose to look the way she does why she
chose the certain human to mimic and we
find out that she pretty much did it to
infiltrate Nick Fury because here's
something important to remember Bara is
the one who brought gravic to Nick Fury
so Vara and grabik were probably very
close graphic was probably like a son to
borrow so when he decided to rebel and
form a resistance she probably was
pretty frustrated with Talos and Nick
Fury as well and decided to join him and
it actually sounds like this was the
plan for a very long time because we
know that her and fury have been married
for a decent amount of time and she was
trying to infiltrate him before they
even met but what ended up happening is
that she fell in love with him this
comes back to the poem that she read him
in 2000 12. Fury recites the poem which
is really him literally asking her did
she get what she wanted out of this life
because he knows what the answer is what
she was seeking and that is for her to
feel beloved and she confirms yes she
did feel beloved which means she did
feel that Nick Fury loved her so she
clearly loved him back and this is why
she misses him and this is why he misses
her they love each other and she's
willing to accept the consequences the
consequences being gravic and this other
scroll rava are probably going to come
for her at some point in time to kill
her meanwhile we have Talos meeting with
his daughter Gaia and this scene shows
us that she is still kind of torn
between what is right and wrong for her
people she says that she returned to her
father because she feels like that's
where she belongs but she also states
that graphic has implemented a plan and
it works so Dad what is your plan how
are you going to find our people at home
and Talos doesn't exactly have the best
plan he basically states that he's going
to prevent World War III from happening
go to the president tell them about the
scroll tell them about how they
prevented the human population from
basically being extinct and demand a
piece of land on Earth that would fit
the millions of skrull who need a home
however Gaia isn't okay with this and
she leaves and if Talos really is dead
this is unfortunately the last
conversation she would have had with her
father so then Fury goes to Roadie or
who we now know to be rabba because they
finally revealed this to us as she's
taking a shower she steps out and turns
into Roadie and at this point Nick Perry
knows that as well because he was spying
on his wife and discovered that Roadie
was a scroll so Fury helps himself into
rava's hotel room where he really only
has one plan get rava to drink the
liquor that he brought because it is
going to put a liquid tracking device
inside of her that way he can track
Roadie to get to gravic and fury
basically says hey I know you're a
scroll I know grabbeck is leading the
Rebellion but rava plays it cool and
basically says look this is the footage
that we have right here it's of you in
Russia it's of you can Maria hill I'll
use this against you and there's no way
you can say that aliens took your
identity and disguised themselves as you
to kill Maria Hill and to plan a Russian
attack they had to hit us in the fields
again with Maria Hill but the plan works
rava drinks the liquor and gets the
tracking device put inside of her and
this leads us to the big battle at the
end where there are some major things
that we have to talk about that take
place here the president arrives and
England where he is greeted by Roadie or
at least that's who he thinks it is of
course we of course know it's rava and
once rava gets inside of her own car she
phones graphic and says hey the
president is in position four basically
confirming where the president is
located which car and gravity comes in
with other Scrolls disguised as Russians
and this is part of gravic's Master Plan
the president of the United States was
there in England to meet with Russia
they are there to talk about the attacks
that took place in Russia that the
scroll did but were disguised as
Americans and now the scroll are
disguised as the Russians attacking the
United States President because cause
remember Graphics master plan is to
essentially start World War III he wants
the humans taken out and he's already
stated in previous episodes that they
will kill each other so graphic wants to
start World War Three so the humans
start killing each other and then the
scroll will come in and clean up the
remaining humans and then they will
claim Earth for themselves and since now
the world is going to believe that the
Russians attacked the US president that
is essentially a guaranteed war between
Russia and the United States and all of
their allies going at war with each
other as well so that's a really big
part of this scene right here graphic
succeeded in his plan another part of
his plan was to intentionally kill Talos
in front of Nick Fury ravik has already
said he could kill Nick Fury if he
wanted to but to truly torture Nick Fury
you do that by taking out everybody that
he loves everybody around him that's one
his wife although that plan didn't
really go according to Graphics plan two
his best friend Maria Hill and then his
other best friend Palos and he made it a
point to do it in front of Nick Fury in
front of Nick Fury where Nick Fury could
not do anything to save Talos because in
that moment graphic could have easily
have killed Nick Fury there as well but
he just wanted him to suffer even more
so he didn't and he killed tales in
front of him instead now is Taylor's
really dead we're not exactly sure yet
however in some trailers we have seen a
scene where Gaia is crying on top of a
body this of course is going to be her
father Talos however what she could do
to possibly bring Talos back is to take
him and go put him in the super scroll
machine perhaps then he could get the
extremist and that could heal him
perhaps it might not be too late for
that however they would have to fly into
Russia which would be pretty hard
especially after the Russians just
attacked the United States in the
Public's eyes perhaps somehow Gaia can
use the extremist that she has to heal
him but for now I am gonna say that he's
probably dead they killed off Maria Hill
and it looks like the stakes are just as
high here killing off Talos however it
wasn't in vain because two other really
important things happened here one is
that when the backup came from the
United States they recognized Nick Fury
they recognized that Fury was trying to
protect and extract the president and
they fought with him so clearly he is
not a huge enemy to the US at this point
in time perhaps later but not now so
that's a really important part but
another one is that the soldiers
actually saw Talos in his scroll form in
his alien form one of the soldiers saw
him and tries to turn on him thinking
that he's trying to attack the president
but Fury says no he's with me the
soldiers realized that the alien is
trying to help protect the president and
if you notice at this point in time
bravic has not yet turned into this
Soldier so it is indeed that actual
soldier that saw him and other soldiers
around as well it's not until after that
graphic turns into that soldier who saw
him and then kills Talos and this is
really important because this is one
step towards the humans being able to
co-exist with the scroll the good scroll
at least this is setting up his future
in which humans and scroll can exist
together realizing that scroll can
actually help the human race which is
why I say talos's death wasn't in vain
he died trying to save the president of
the United States and United States
soldiers saw that and will be able to
attest that scroll some of them at least
and hopefully the majority of them are
good so hopefully this makes a
difference and Talos did not die in vain
also another thing that graphic made
Fury do is choose between the president
or Talos which one to save another part
of Graphics torture for Nick Fury and so
far graphic has proven to be a great
villain in the MCU because he truly is
Savage and he is ruthless and he is
doing an amazing job at torturing Nick
Fury and making him suffer but that is
episode 4 of secret Invasion please let
us know what you're thinking about the
show so far do you like it do you not
like it and why either way let us know
why and drop any and all predictions you
have for episode 5 and six in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
videos if you want to further support
the channel you can check us out on
patreon you can check out our website
and our Discord server as well and of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf
foreign